Resuelve la ecuación
2x cuadrada más 3 es igual a 75.
Y la buena noticia que te tengo
es que la "x"
la podemos despejar
fácilmente de esta ecuación.
Si nosotros lo que hacemos
son operaciones elementales,
vamos a poder obtener las raíces
de esta ecuación cuadrática.
Así que antes que nada
déjame escribir aquí de nuevo la ecuación,
y me queda,
2x cuadrada más 3 igual a 75
y ahora sí, lo que quiero es despejar a la "x" cuadrada, porque fíjate
que en esta ocasión no tenemos a "x" cuadrada,
y a una "x" a la primera potencia.
Por lo tanto como primer paso voy a restar 3
de ambos lados de la ecuación,
y me queda 2x cuadrada,
este 3 con este 3 se van
y después 75 menos 3 es 72,
y ahora como quiero despejar "x" cuadrada,
me estorba este 2 que tengo aquí,
por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer es fijarme
que este 2 está multiplicando el "x" cuadrada,
y por lo tanto,
voy a dividir ambos lados de la ecuación entre 2,
2 entre 2 se van,
me da 1
y entonces del lado izquierdo de la ecuación
solamente me queda "x" cuadrada
y 72 entre 2 me da 36,
la mitad de 72 es 36.
¡Perfecto!
Y ahora lo único que me falta hacer
es pasar este cuadrado que yo tengo aquí
en la "x" cuadrada
pero si yo quiero pasar
un cuadrado del otro lado de la ecuación,
lo paso con su operación inversa
y su operación inversa es la raíz cuadrada.
Entonces lo que voy a hacer es sacar la raíz cuadrada
del lado izquierdo de la ecuación,
me va a quedar "x"
y le voy a sacar raíz cuadrada
del otro lado de la ecuación
pero recuerda
que cuando saco la raíz cuadrada,
tengo 2 raíces una positiva y una negativa.
Por lo tanto "x" es igual
a más menos la raíz de 36
y deja mejor ponerlo abajo,
para que quede mucho más claro.
Voy a ponerlo aquí "x" es igual a más menos
la raíz de 36 que es 6
¡Y ojo! Ya tenemos 2 raíces
una raíz positiva,
es decir x1 es igual a 6,
y una raíz negativa,
que es x2 igual a -6
ya tengo las 2 raíces,
de esta ecuación cuadrática.
Ahora mi pregunta es
¿Serán realmente estas raíces?
Pues nada nos cuesta verificar
que realmente si sean estas raíces,
así que voy a sustituir al 6 primero
para ver si x1 igual a 6,
va a cumplir con la ecuación con la que empezamos,
y dice,
6 al cuadrado 36 por 2, 72 más 3, 75.
¡Perfecto!
Si cumple y si pongo -6
pues me va a dar lo mismo,
porque -6 al cuadrado también es 36.